Baker why can't you just drink your soda
like a normal person because so it
tastes better if you drink it out of a
Godzilla shaped pitcher so you put the
cannon right there but like that and you
made small that is also i didn't get one
of those i want that i call it I call it
what you call it can't call it my all
the way from Tokyo yeah but that's this
video game related how is it video game
that's you right man that was it up
200 foot tall is it Phyllis soda vomited
all
you know rock band is a great game to
play with your friends but if you're
like me and you don't have any friends
you probably already figured out that
one of the most compelling single-player
things to do with rock band is the
drumming now I really actually like
harmonics is drum controller they've put
together for rock band it's pretty
sturdy maybe with one exception the
included foot pedal now that yeah it's
made out of plastic doesn't really give
you a whole lot of resistance kind of
prone to breaking if you play with it
too too much but let me tell you if you
want to take your game to the next level
if you're looking for a drum pedal
that's maybe a lot more powerful maybe a
little more expensive I want to check
out the Omega pedal the Omega pedal is
actually an honest-to-goodness drum
pedal this is a musician's instrument
manufactured by pearl that these guys
have hatched some rock band sensors on
to and so you can use it as a foot pedal
for your drum controller what the Omega
pedal is not is plug and play the first
thing I did when I took it out of the
box and did the minor bits of assembly
and started playing with it is basically
broke the thing because I didn't realize
okay well you've got to adjust these
nuts down here on this changes the
tension on this spring which is what
changes the amount of pressure that you
need to put on the pedal and how much
it's going to spring back up at you and
of course you can make you know little
minor adjustments to this so it feels
just right for you you also have to
adjust how the beater right here strikes
the hook the hook is what's going to
hold it on to the polls in the bottom of
your drum set but it also is where this
beater right here strikes and what this
is going to do when you're playing is
give you a really really nice drum sound
way better than that and that plastic
thing and finally around here on this
side you can see this is where they've
actually put in the the sensor and the
wire and if you look right here every
time you hit the drum pedal it's going
to hit this little tiny sensor right
here this thing kind of swings around
and that's what's sending the
information to the game that you are in
fact pressing the drum pedal
now as you can see if the beater is not
striking the hook squarely you will
absolutely shred this foam pad luckily
the Omega pedal does come with three
extra pads so if you're not doing it
exactly correctly right you do have a
little bit of wiggle room now you might
notice that the Omega pedal kind of
pretty much looks like it was hacked
together by some guys in their garage
yeah that the sensor right here is
pretty much taped onto the side but
really you know it is actually put
together very nicely and it is only
eighty dollars which you know you've
already spent 170 in rock bands so it's
another 80 you can get it at Omega pedal
com today's secret word is polymorphic
content yeah yeah I know it sounds like
some kind of a horrible disease but um
it is actually in a way you see when I
when square and Enix merged back in 2003
they decided the best way to leverage
their combined multimedia talents would
be to create entire Suites of games
manga movies mobile content that all
used the same assets one of their first
dalliance is with the concept is a
series based on their classic title
Final Fantasy 7 which so far has
basically sucked the movie advent
children was incomprehensible the cell
phone game was utterly forgettable and
seriously who thought it was a good idea
for Square Enix the RPG company to make
a first person shooter luckily crisis
core final fantasy 7 and RPG for the PSP
is actually a good game finally crisis
core blends traditional role playing
battle elements with a little bit of
twitch based action to tell the story of
the events that transpired before the
classic PlayStation 1 game I won't bore
you with the details suffice it to say
that you just control one character
whose name is Zack yes he does look a
lot like cloud from the first game with
black hair look if you're not used to
Final Fantasy characters all looking
alike right now I don't know what to
tell you when he's thrown into battle
against monsters zach has most of the
traditional Final Fantasy options
available to him fighting magic items
all that good stuff
but battles take place in 3d arenas and
you've actually got to dodge enemy
attacks not just stand there it's an
interesting combination of traditional
Final Fantasy turn-based battles with
some action its main flaws that it's all
incredibly easy you can just mash on the
X button all day without touching
anything else and you'll probably race
through the first few hours of gameplay
sure occasionally you'll need to dodge
attacks or maybe you'll want to use a
new spell you found but deeper strategy
not needed it really this is a game for
devoted final fantasy 7 fans who want to
watch the story transpire and in that
sense crisis core truly delivers the
graphics are absolutely amazing for the
PSP the cutscenes are high production
big budget affairs that are scattered
liberally throughout the game and unlike
the aforementioned incomprehensible
movie advent children you'll be into
this story even if you haven't played
the original game crisis core final
fantasy 7 actually came out at the end
of March but Kohler you might be asking
yourself why are you reviewing it now
well shut up and i'll tell you i've been
playing crisis core the way it's
intended to be played as a portable game
you know for a few minutes on the bus or
when I need to kill some time I can't
really see playing it for three to four
hours at a stretch I'm not sure it would
be as much fun but for 10 to 30 minutes
it's a great portable time killer that's
why I'm giving it an 8 out of 10
you